cheese never stops the cheese never hey
guys it's katie and this is my husband
chris hi
and today we're gonna cook together
in the same kitchen
it's gonna be
delicious
so i thought what would be really fun is
if we tried to recreate our first date
dinner yes which was deep dish pizza
from a place here called masa of ecco
park and i remember picking that place
because it takes 45 minutes for them to
even make it so it was a lot more time
for us to actually hang out is that
really why you picked it yeah wait
seriously yeah no way
yes a little bit about this deep dish
pizza they're huge they're cheesy yeah
there's sausage in it which is delicious
the people that make it are from chicago
yes it's legit we've well we think it's
legit we've never been to chicago so
don't come for us we're gonna be sharing
a pizza of our history
[Laughter]
[Music]
to get started
we are gonna make the dough first yes i
know that dough includes flour
and water and um love oh
that's cute gross okay so first thing
we're going to do is we have some warm
water here we have about a cup and a
quarter cool so we'll add our sugar
great mix that together
and then we're going to add the yeast
and sprinkle that on top let this bloom
for about five minutes bloom it just
means it's like gonna get activated see
how it's already starting to form
ripples it already smells like dough
[Music]
next steps we're going to add flour and
some cornmeal that's perfect got it
that's salt in there whoa and then we
should whisk that together just to make
sure everything gets well combined
they're doing it a little delicately
well i'm getting more confident i'm
getting warmer gosh this is crazy i
believe in myself that looks whisked are
you trying to make a pond about it no
wasn't true i would have said this is
the whiskiest part of the whole
recipe because i might smell everywhere
now we're going to add the yeast
concoction and then we need to add the
butter all right okay and then you want
to do this okay you could do this with
your hand too this is where i feel like
if you were making this with a kid this
would be fun they could yes they could
squish with their hands you're trying to
say you want to have kids right now
so you're going to mix this until it
becomes a shaggy dough let's add some
flour to the table top
okay
too much
so when you follow our surface spread it
out so it's a light dusting and not like
a bunch of flowers can be added to your
recipe right all right this is like too
much got it
so should i just sweep all this out of
here no that's fine it's fine we'll just
stay away from that stay away from my
area because uh it sucks we're gonna
just
wow wow wow wow this guy out we're gonna
mix it together with our hands okay
maybe i should have brought it more
together in the bowl no turning back now
all right you want to take over yes push
away and come back you just push away
the bad thoughts pull in the good push
away the bad are we there let's see does
it spring back quickly yeah
so we put some oil in the bowl and we
put the dough inside and then we're
going to top it
with plastic wrap plastic wrap and then
we'll set this in a warm place for about
one to two hours so it can double in
size great find someplace warm
flour on your face
can you get it off yes
great now we're even now i'm a real chef
we're gonna clean up and then we're
gonna get working on the sauce next i'm
excited all right i love sauce
sausage let's get started
next we're going to make the tomato
sauce which on this pizza is like one of
the best parts yeah i feel like it's the
most important the acid from the tomato
really helps balance like the fatty
cheese yes oh that was smart thank you
we have got some san marzano
whole tomatoes and we're going to put
those through a strainer so next crisp
we're going to need to crush these
tomatoes with their hands so we're just
gonna get in there and really just
squeeze and smush them yes because we
want to get out any water got it from
the sauce so that we don't have a soggy
pizza okay great so do you wanna yeah
yeah i'll get in there
whoa
wow this would be fun if i was a kid
stop talking about kids do you want
children yes
all right i feel like that's good you've
crushed them well we'll transfer them to
a saucepan great
[Music]
we're gonna add some sugar delicious red
pepper flakes red pepper flakes salt bam
olive oil pow last but not least we're
gonna do four cloves of grated garlic we
are cooking this down to get the water
and excess liquid off so the pizza is
not super soggy bam
powder
pow
delish all right when we were ordering
chris tried to order two of these deep
dishes the server was like sir
that's obscene you're gonna get kicked
out of here okay this looks nice and
reduced we're gonna turn the heat off
and we're gonna add in some fresh basil
next we're gonna make mushrooms yes we
are first thing we'll do
melt some butter yes add in
some mushrooms beautiful
whoa
i'm gonna use the lightest touch you're
gonna let this saute for about five
minutes i think we're almost there and
then i've got a little salt here
so we're just gonna season it with a
little salt yeah we'll set those off to
the side let them cool awesome and then
one last thing it's time to prepare the
sausage one of my favorite parts about
this pizza is that it has a huge like
sausage patty on the top so good it's
delicious it's crispy yes first thing
we're gonna do is toast some fennel
toasting it is just really gonna bring
out that fennel flavor it makes it more
aromatic yes is that a word there you go
so delicious
we missed that but it doesn't matter
toast this for about three to four
minutes until they start turning brown
then we're gonna transfer them to a
cutting board awesome we're gonna chop
it up you want to do it love it yeah
i'll chop
nice looks good
add this to some italian sausage
without getting it everywhere
okay and then you want to mix it
together let's do it you need to hold it
yeah yeah you hold it i think that looks
good awesome all right so next we have
two pieces of parchment put the sausage
into the parchment so we're basically
making like a meat frisbee
yes
gross
and then we're gonna put
this parchment on top of our meat
frisbee
and then we can kind of just use
just hands you know what might be easier
is like a rolling pin yeah i can get it
teamwork guys there's a rolling pin wow
wow it's not really a circle anymore
that's pretty good yeah i think i have
to lift this up oh all right all right
so our sausage disc broke a little bit
put it back together
that is that's almost nine inches this
looks like a massive pepperoni it looks
like a big pepperoni it looks like we're
putting one one huge
[Laughter]
okay
and then we're gonna assemble boom kiss
to assemble
[Music]
boom whoa that dough is huge we are not
going to use this whole thing it would
be that this is two pizzas worth of
dough awesome so we're gonna flour our
surface i'll let you do that
do you think you know how to do that i
think i know how to do it more like
fancy more magician
take the dough cut them in half all
right let's do it and then i'm going to
put this in a freezer bag and you can
freeze this dough for up to one month
and make another pizza awesome next
we're going to put our dough in a cast
iron pan because the cast iron holds a
lot of heat and makes the dough super
crispy yes add a little olive oil to the
cast iron pan and you can use a paper
towel to
spread it so we're going to smash this
thing into there now yeah i think we can
just add it in and it should be easy
enough to work that we can just spread
it out you want to make sure it just
goes all the way up the sides of the pan
our first date should have been going to
a deep dish pizza place it should have
been making a deep dish pizza well yeah
though i don't really go over to
people's houses on the first day yeah
you never know
oh my gosh sorry yeah yeah looks good so
the next thing we're going to add
is cheese oh my gosh mozzarella cheese
how much of this are we using the whole
thing whoa
it's gonna be worth it that's crazy so
that you're gonna tear it and we're
gonna add it to the bottom the thing
about chicago deep dish is that the
cheese goes under the sauce next thing
we're going to do is add our mushrooms
on top it looks perfect you want to add
the sauce i would love to add the sauce
all right all right
you're doing great you're doing great i
felt like i did great this is the real
test
can we put a giant frisbee of sausage
cleanly onto this pizza all right should
i just
i just go for it let's go slam it
oh my
god look at that last thing you need to
add is some shredded parmesan on top
let's put this on a sheet pan boom this
is to make sure no mozzarella cheese
boils over and burns yes not gonna have
a cheese volcano spilling in the oven no
so we're gonna put this in the oven at
what 425 for how long 35 to 40 minutes
good job
here we go whoa
it looks perfect i'm shocked by how
close we got it all right do you want to
give it a cut i would love to do the
honors like our like a wedding you do
it's too dangerous
[Music]
let's pull it up
oh my gosh
keep pulling the cheese never stops the
cheese never i am four feet above the
pizza and the cheese just broke now
wait that looks exactly like this that
looks
perfect should we dry it yes let's do it
oh my gosh
that is really good
that's really good
the sauce the sauce is perfect there's
dynamite cheers cheers
to seven and a half years together and
almost five years of marriage hopefully
hopefully 30 more at least
i plan on living longer than that
how old is that how old does that make
us 16. it's like 60. okay i'd like to
live longer than 60 to 100 more years
[Music]
you